[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes
depuis vingt ans la france ne cesse de
reculer tant à l'intérieur qu'à
l'extérieur
elle a perdu progressivement son
indépendance et sa souveraineté
juridique monétaire budgétaire
industriel et social au bénéfice de
l'europe de bruxelles et du mondialisme
plus grave encore l'armée gage de notre
sécurité extérieure a été démantelé une
folle politique d'immigration massive
entraînée d'arriver chez nous 2 millions
d'étrangers du tiers-monde
avec des conséquences dramatiques sur le
chômage l'insécurité et le fiscalisme la
police et la justice sont de plus en
plus impuissante et la peur s'installe
dans les villes et les villages
l'industrie l'agriculture le commerce
l'artisanat régresse tandis que les
charges fiscales et sociales
s'alourdisse la famille est bafouée
l'école est incapable de former des
citoyens et les professionnels de demain
le racket la drogue et la violence s'y
installe la corruption règne à la tête
de la république
les jeunes trop souvent sans emploi
désespère et les personnes âgées
s'angoisse de leur retraite
le désordre qui s'installe menace bien
sûr d'abord les faibles enfants femmes
pauvres vieux il n'est que temps de
réagir avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
il vous suffit d'écarter les politiciens
discréditer d'élire un chef d'état digne
de ce nom pour changer de politique
pour cela il faut donner la parole au
peuple et le consulter directement par
référendum pour réaliser les réformes
indispensables
je me suis engagé solennellement sur un
programme de redressement national
je vous en propose les grands axes
premièrement restaurer la souveraineté
de la france et lui rendre son
indépendance et son unité lui permettant
ainsi de reprendre son rang dans le
monde
dénonciation des traités europe
actuel restauration de l'indépendance
monétaire construction de l'europe des
nations
deuxièmement rétablir l'ordre et la loi
par une politique de fermeté et de
volonté tolérance zéro pour le crime et
la délinquance certitude de la sanction
pénale référendum sur le rétablissement
de la peine de mort
construction de prisons et de maisons de
correction troisièmement résoudre la
question de l'immigration
expulsion de tous les clandestins
abrogation du regroupement familial
restriction du droit d'asile
rétablissement des contrôles aux
frontières
attribution de la nationalité
exclusivement à ceux qui en sont dignes
et inscrire dans notre constitution le
principe de la préférence nationale
quatrièmement réduire fortement les
impôts et les dépenses publiques en
limitant dans la constitution à 35% du
produit national le taux des
prélèvements obligatoires impôts et
charges qui en ponctionne aujourd'hui
plus de la moitié
cinquièmement donner un emploi à chaque
français grâce à nos petites et moyennes
entreprises et à leurs salariés en leur
donnant les moyens d'assurer leur
développement et leur prospérité et de
tenir leur place dans la compétition
mondiale et enfin de re devenir source
de création d'emplois
sixièmement faire de la famille une
priorité en lançant une politique
généreuse en faveur de la natalité et de
l'accueil de l'enfant avantages sociaux
et fiscaux pour les familles françaises
création du revenu parental et de la
retraite pour la mère de famille
préférence nationale en matière de
logement et d'allocations familiales
septièmement sauver les retraites par le
développement de l'activité économique
la relance de la natalité et en donnant
aux salariés le libre choix de l'âge de
la retraite par répartition est celui
d'un régime optionnel de capitalisation
huitièmement défendre la nature et la
vie en faisant tu à nouveau triompher la
vie sur la culture de mort et en
défendant la véritable écologie
qui est protection raisonnée de la
nature et des créatures vivantes
ce soin des animaux de compagnie ou
d'élevage pour une fois le choix va être
clair si vous trouvez que tout va bien
et que demain cela ira encore mieux
votre thé chirac ou jospin c'est la même
chose
si en revanche vous craignez pour votre
avenir celui de vos enfants et celui de
la france je suis le seul candidat qui
soit en mesure d'être au deuxième tour
et de pouvoir ainsi changer la vie
quelles que soient vos préférences pour
un loisir comme la chasse ou une nuance
politique
le seul vote utile c'est le vote le pen
merci
[Musique]